.
AROTIDENT DEN JUST
HIM AND HI
HEDMITS  SHOULD HAVE
TO TAKE RESPONSI FOR THE
MOAPWEREO FOLLOWING AL TPOLITICI
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE A
ESFOR NENOG OUT.
ALSOS
Y GETTIN
FINAL GREEN
PANDEMIC NOW THAT NEARLY 95% OF
ALL AMERICANS ARTUALLYO GEA SHO?
WE WANT TO WELCOME OUR VIERSIN
I' BLITZER
ITUATION ROOM."
>>IS IS CN NEWH
DEMOCRATSRES  OUT RRE
ND TRIGGERIN
FIG WITH
O OUCHIEF NATI
RELOSS I. PRESIDENT BING RESPON
DLSY THAT
BIG  ORRY M
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR THERE WAS
GRIDLOCK IN
E DID CALLN SS TO   IE PASSED
BEFOUT I'M NOT
SURE TT N ABLE
E CHANGED THE NURVATIVE FOLKS W
TURNED OUT IN THE REUMP T MAYBE.
>> OF COURSEERMANY
MO VS AS CONSERVATIV
RS IN RED D
THE WHITE HOUSE, BHE
PREN THEUSTRATIO B
AMERICANS.
>> THERE'S A WHOOT O
ER
GO COVID UNDER
CONTROL?Y KI TO INSCHOOL?NG N
OF MFALY>>THT CERTAINLY
GEDAH CONGRESS BUT Y NLD CHAIN
HIS
THAT THEOU
WORK OUT THEIRRENCES
WHICH, OSE, REMAIN LARGE.
HE SAID SIMPLY, WOLFT IT TO
MY DEST YOTAY 'LL BRING YOU BAC
OU I WANT TO GETS AND
THL PAHE NEY RACLOSEO
CALL.
THDT ME SAEN W
Y CENL
REPUBLICANS DELIVERED
BLOW TO DEMOCRATS IN THE
BIDEN TOOK
THAT GIA AS LOSER THANPECTEDERRE
S REVEALING TELLIN
SIGNS ABOUE COUNTRY AND THE ISSS
ARE LOOKING FOR LESSONS HEADING
INTOEXT YEAR'S MIDTERMS.
>>G HIGH AFTER
>>E WON THIS THING. NG GOP
BUSINESSMAN GLEN YOUNGKIN AS
GOVERNORE YEAR
ND JOE
BIDEN TO THEHITHE ONAY WE'RE
G  MORNING SAYING  CAMPAIGRGET
WHILE LAST NIGHT WE
PROUDHAT WE SPENT
THIS CAMPAIGN FIGHTING FOR
LIE IN.MERATS CHOINUP
ACE
PRESIDS AG LAST NIGHT?
>> TO DELIVER. OUR INABILITY T
HIM.OTERCRATS ON
IN NEW JERSEY WHERE
6 POINTS.
YET BE THETONIGHT
O BE REPUBLICAN DRUMBEAT
W CADING NPREST OM A TRIP ABROA
?
DISAPPROVED OF THE
PERFORMANCE O FUELED
N'20 EXP RUR AREAS WON B
S WHERE OUR
GORN.
WE WILL GO TE
FRUSTRATIS  PLE.
SCHOOLKS TO WH
AUGHT.D E, AND I
THINK E  DEMOCRATIC
SIDE HAVE TOIT BACK D THINK
OUW  THAT.
THE RACERUMP AT S NG
FOCUSING ON ISSUES A
DEMOCRAT OTHER PARTSTHE COUNTRY
D MAR OFEW YORK CITY
AND TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE DEPA
OF PUBLIC D HISTORY ALSOE
OF COLLE FOR THE FIRST
TIMEIERNOR AND BOSTON'S NEXT
YEAR'S MID-TERTIONS HOPING FLIP
STATE OFTHEY'RO ABSORB THE
LESSONS LEARNED, ATHEY'R
FAN  CRIME AND A
MUCH MERCKAL SMERCISE Y
RPVE
N ABLE TO PROJEC
WHAT MESSAGE ARE VOTERS SEND
TO DRAMESSAG WATCHED
THTHD I THINTH
T OF ANALYSIS EY
BUY TH
REPUBLICANS HAVE BET  I B
SPF
BETTER DINISSUES THAT
DRIVE PEOPLEO THPOENGENDER PONKE
ORHEY THE TYPEF ISSUES
FIRE PEOPLE UP I
ELECTION TO GO TO TH REALL
PO MAKE,
MICHAEL.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HISLEGISLATI
PASSED BEFORE ELECTIONIT WOU HA
REALA DIFFEREN
DEMOCRATS WERE FIGHTING OVER HIS
SPNGLAN, THEY LOSE
PRLEE E FACING.
HAEL POINTS
RITH
NEVER-ENDING COVITY
YE AND
THE STRESS AND THE PRESSURE OF
OBD CERTS WITH VACCINES, BUT
ICK OF SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
BEE THESE NBA LONG  IN  OOTHE.
LI IF YER , ,
WHY YOU THINK IT IS GOING IN THE
WRONG DICT
HAVE THAING
BOGGED DOWN IN SAUSAGE
MANGE BILLS, R
O ILL, AND
THAT ALSO MIGHT BE IMPORTANT TT
ONCE THEY T THOS
S LLVERSION OF THESSEDEVENE ENOG
STILL WHERS RIGHT IF GAS PRICES
THIS PERNIANTI-INCUMBENT M AS
DEMOND THAT IS THA
YOUN AT THE SAURN T N-AMER V